I'm Michaela Bennett I'm a junior here
at Hillsdale I'm an American Studies
major and as some of you guys already
know I talked to you earlier I'm a
journalism minor so this CCA is very
near and dear to my heart and I'm here
to welcome mr. Tim Groseclose did I say
it correctly nosey okay so Tim
Groseclose is a professor of economics
at George Mason University where he
holds the Adam Smith chair at the
university's Marcaida Center he earned
his BS in mathematical and computational
sciences from Stanford University and
his PhD from the Stanford Graduate
School of Business where he focused on
political economy his scholarly articles
have been published in numerous journals
including the American Economic Review
quarterly Journal of economics the
American Political Science Review the
American Journal political science in
Journal of politics he is the author of
two books including cheating and
insiders report on the use of race and
admissions at UCLA and left-turn how
liberal media bias distorts the American
mind please join me in welcoming mr. Tim
Groseclose
well thank you Makayla and thank you
very much for welcoming to Hillsdale
this is my first time here and but
there's been a warm spot in my heart for
Hillsdale for several years now and I've
been wanting to come and I'm so pleased
finally to be here my talk today is
going to be a little bit different from
the other talks that you've seen in fact
mine is more like a lecture and they by
a college professor which I am but
instead of a genuine speech I'm going to
use PowerPoint uh and I've got to warn
you there's gonna be an equation or two
in there so uh Matt bell one of the
organizers asked me last night said we
you need anything for your talk and I
said well maybe coffee for the audience
and so no no Matt I'm not joking and and
there really is I will not be offended
if any of you need coffee I will be
offended if you don't come back but I
think I have some important stuff and if
you do get bored just get coffee come
back okay cuz this stuff I believe that
I'm talking about is very important okay
one other for a quick personal
disclosure so uh one just a few months
ago I earned fifty another personal
disclosure seven months ago I left you
see laughs as a professor at UCLA bar is
in the political science department and
I moved to the economics department at
George Mason as I sometimes joke for my
midlife crisis I became an economist
thank you
so let me say why that's relevant all
the research for this book I did when I
was a political scientist okay before my
midlife crisis while I was a political
scientist and now I believe that
political science really can be a
science that we can do things like test
hypotheses we can measure things and
that's where I tried doing this book
that's in particular I try to measure
for instance the political views of
politicians I try to measure come up
with a number that is that says that the
actual slant of different media outlets
and then the third thing I wanted I do
in this book is try to measure the
effects of the bias now John Miller
asked me to come here and talk about the
effects of media usually when I give
this talk I concentrate on the first two
questions for today I'm going to
concentrate on this third so I'm going
to just fly through these first two
questions but give a quick summary okay
oh yeah let me explain this and the
other thing that once we answer these
questions and with a few I think
reasonable assumptions in a very simple
mathematical model we can answer some
counterfactual questions in the main one
I want to answer is how would America
think and vote if it weren't for the
media bias we can magically get rid of
it what would happen and I'm gonna give
away the punchline the answer is
approximately like Texas okay so that
that's where I'm going okay by the way
let me also say that the same question
the same answer corresponds to the
question what if we could get rid of the
effects and that is what if we could
make everyone aware of the bias and make
everyone discount it rationally in the
sense that economists use a term and the
answer is again America would look like
Texas okay that's according to my
results at least okay part one political
quotients how do we measure political
views now this is actually fairly easy
all you need is a survey and I've given
all of you I call it homework I think
everyone should have a little page on
you so it's ten questions you can
compute your own political quotient I
encourage everyone to do that this
political quotient all of these
questions are based on roll call votes
so the beauty of that is that I have the
answers that politicians would give to
these questions and so I have the I can
compute the political quotient of
different politicians so once you get
your score you can compare yourself how
you compare to these different politics
on the scale by the way the political
quotient basically says how liberal you
are high scores mean more liberal a zero
is pretty conservative something like a
Michele Bachmann or Jim DeMint excuse me
a 100 is something like a Nancy Pelosi
there's some and there's some technical
reasons you can actually score higher
than that some of you may remember the
Grenada invasion where we found these
minutes from this group of Marxist that
their their meeting that they had and
they were talking about congressman Ron
Dellums
the representative from Berkley I would
say a compliment to my scores I found he
is very very liberal on this even to the
left of Nancy Pelosi I won't go into the
details but I guesstimate that the
average PQ the average political
quotient of all American voters is about
fifty point four okay if you want some
what that means substantively that means
about like a rhino or a Blue Dog
Democrat I estimate Arlen Specter when
he was a Republican as fifty point six
so when I say average American voter I
mean about the views of Arlen Specter I
hope she doesn't mind me revealing this
I cornered cheryl atkinson last night
and and I said you know gave her my card
I said here's my PQ test go to my
website said I think a lot of people
think you're you know like far-right but
I've been reading your book and her
drive I think you're 50 on my PQ score
and she said hope she doesn't mind me
saying this yeah I think you're right
and I said and I also think that that
fifty is far right in the CBS newsroom
and she said yeah I think you're right I
think you're right so uh I will see her
cornered Hugh Hewitt maybe he'll tell us
this he said he was he told me he's to
the right of John McCain left the
Michelle Bachman so he's somewhere
between zero and sixteen by the way my
scores of thirteen on this so anyway
those are the PQ scores there's a number
of technical issues about this I'm happy
to answer them in the QA part one is how
do I use these to compare scores over
time so
do some controversial things one thing I
say that John F Kennedy according to my
scores is more conservative than Joe
Lieberman lots people say happy you know
exactly that can't be but that's what I
find how can you do that they served in
different terms and and the answer it's
it's a technical problem but its uses
kind of the same technology that a
teacher uses to curve exams so if people
score lower on one exam the same people
have taken to the two exams if the same
people score lower on one you could just
add some points to there and that curves
the the scales so the two tests are
similar after you've curved them it's a
technical issue I wrote about it in a
peer-reviewed paper in the American
Political Science Review I had two
co-authors one was Jim Snyder who was an
MIT at the time now he's at Harvard in
the government department and Economics
Department and another co-author was a
very bright grad student at MIT named
Steve Levitan
quick show of hands who has heard of
Steve Levitt only a few I think some
more hands are gonna go up he's the
author of Freakonomics okay so I'm gonna
Pat myself on the back for a second 1994
he's a grad student I see this guy is
smart I I realized this not only that
and I have people who can verify this a
few months after meeting him I said
Steve's gonna win a Nobel Prize someday
I know I'm gonna be right by the way and
by the way I verified this with Steve I
was the first person ever to predict
that not even his parents were
predicting he would win a Nobel Prize so
by the way so when I talk about these PQ
scores I had helped one of them was
Steve Levitt okay so that is measuring
political views let's talk about now
measuring the slant of the media this
again comes from a peer-reviewed paper
with my co-author Jeff Milo good friend
best best man at my wedding the less
good-looking guy and and we published a
paper in the quarterly Journal of
economics coming up with what I now call
slant quotients it's just a number to
say how liberal or
conservative is the media outlet okay so
that paper it's on my website wants to
read it's 48 pages long I'd encourage
you only read one page there's this
figure too okay and I'm going to try to
give the quick version of what we do in
that paper in the key thing is we come
up with what I now call slant quotients
dad we've talked about political
quotients that I'm gonna talk about
slant quotients so here's an example so
if you look at on the right I'm gonna do
the third one down so New York Times
follow the arrow down it's probably hard
to see with for a lot of you follow it
down you've you see a tick mark and it's
right by Joe Lieberman's name so what
that means is that our method found that
the average New York Times article
sounds about like a Joe Lieberman speech
okay so more specific the way we did
that is we had a sample of think tanks
about 200 think tanks we have a
statistical method that finds that the
New York Times when it cites these think
tanks it picks a mix of left-wing verses
right wing versus centrist think tanks
about the same that Joe Lieberman picks
when he about the same mix at Joe
Lieberman picks when he makes speeches
on the Senate floor okay so we find a
New York Times article the average New
York Times article sounds about like the
average Joe Lieberman speech so then our
method just says what's joe lieberman's
PQ what's his political quotient and we
find by his vote score rating since 75
so our method assigns a 75 as the slant
quotient of the New York Times okay so
we do this for 20 news outlets we post
them on that there's a curious result
well let me go over some of the results
one lots people asked Wall Street
Journal it turns out the most liberal by
our method please ask me in the Q&A
about what happened there the the quick
answer is that it doesn't include op eds
even then it still seems a little high
and I have reasons why I think that
happened another result though
is that we looked at 20 news outlets you
probably can't see all the the names of
all these turns out all 18 of the 20 I
think would be called mainstream media
outlets 2 would be called people I think
would call conservative outlets washing
times and special report with turns out
with Brit Hume I did this when Britain
was still the anchor 18 out of the 20
all the mainstream news outlets were
left of center they had a slant quotient
above 50 okay
they range basically from about 62 to 80
or so only 2 were a right-of-center
and even those two weren't far right for
instance special report is only about a
40 on there so we found that special
report sounds about like a rhino speech
about like a Susan Collins or Olympia
Snowe speech Washington Times was just a
teeny bit more conservative it also was
almost like a rhino speech although
definitely right-of-center okay so
that's the the main result so imagine
maybe also say no you know we find all
the mainstream media to the left of
center they're not really far left of
center well for instance the average
Democrat has a PQ of 85 we find that the
slant quotient for none of them is above
85 so that all about all the mainstream
media is between 50 and 85 but
definitely a little bit to the left of
center one other thing I'll come back to
this graph in my book I try to estimate
what I think is the average slant
quotient of the entire US media once you
factor in talk radio internet everything
cable news and I get about fifty eight
point five I get eight points to the
left of center by the way s qs and PQ is
high numbers are liberal so
unfortunately on this graph liberal is
on the right of this so but anyway 58.5
it's about eight points higher than
fifty point four so that's I find the
media's bias about eight points to the
left of center okay next what I really
want to talk about measuring the effects
of
- okay so I'm gonna talk I want to talk
about the effects and to the huh got
some of my estimates of this but first I
want to talk something about what is
calling dodging 80 problems it's an
ocean from econometrics very important
notion and it's in dodging 80 problems
or pandemic in social science problems
especially with trying to estimate the
media effects okay here is the the
equation I'm going to skip it okay all I
want to say though is if there any
students in here I think that's very
important in your college education to
learn or didn't dodge an ad problem is
taking a Conor metrics class that's
that's where you learn that I think
that's very important to learn okay I'm
not gonna give the full version of what
an endogenous problem is that takes
about a year actually to do it justice
in my book I have about six pages on it
I think if you want a twenty to thirty
or forty minute it's good summary I
think my book may be the best on them
I'm gonna give about a five minute
summary of what Ana dodging eighty
problem is I'm gonna do it with an
example with an anecdote and here's your
house here's how the anecdote goes
during the 1950's I think just about
everyone would agree the LA Times was
right-of-center
okay it turns out it had a publisher
owner
it was definitely conservative but at
some point it started going more and
more left it probably happened mainly in
the mid 1960s the the owner transferred
it to a son who had had an education at
Stanford University as I can tell that
tons of left wingers and their it's so
it's not probably no surprise he moved a
little bit left and then by 2015 today I
think it's very it's very not super far
left but definitely let left-of-centre
but my estimate its slant quotient has
shifted about 40 points from about the
1950s okay now if you look at that time
1950s to now you find that the peak hue
of the average LA voter has moved you
know la may have the LA County may be
Moline right in the 1950s now is deaf
leans left votes about 75 25 for the
Democrat in a presidential election so
by my estimate its PQ of the average LA
County voter move about 50 points
leftward the natural conclusion say well
you know the times it's the main news
outlet in LA looks like The Times moved
everyone left this is all because of the
the media effects the problem is there
could be a double causation in here
there are lots of people think about
this what if yeah it seems reasonable to
say that if a news outlet becomes more
moves to the left this will cause voters
and it's its consumers to move to the
left but you could also imagine the
reverse causation that is if just
suppose there's new voters that move
into LA or there's some other reason LA
voters become more liberal if you were
the publisher of the LA Times you
worrying about profits you'd say we got
to move left with our consumers right
with our target audience and so if you
look at that if you did just an
observational study just look at the
numbers and don't do anything like an
experiment you would it turns out
overestimate the true effect of the
media part of that that correlation is
due to the reverse causation okay so
that's key whenever there's something
like an endogenous um thing like a
double causation problem the
correlations are going to give you a
biased estimate and in this case it's
going to cause you to overestimate the
effect now since other cases it will
cause you to underestimate the effect
and often we can use theoretical
reasoning to try to figure out which way
the bias should go another example and
here's where that that effect goes the
opposite way turns out death penalty and
deterrence of murder so you think like
yeah death penalty it's it's got to help
a little in deterring murder but on the
other hand it turns out you look in
states that have the death penalty
according by a lot of studies the murder
rates actually higher in states with
death penalty than those without part of
the reason is because the reverse
causation so if you're if you're in a
state it has a lot of murders you think
we need to put in a death penalty
to stop that so the death penalty the
the murders murder rates could be
causing the policy okay well there's
another causation maybe the policy could
you know cause a deterrent effect on the
murder but you have this double
causation and in this example if you do
just an observational study if you
didn't do an experiment if you just
looked at these correlations you would
underestimate the true effect of the
death penalty
okay so put this in big letters like the
solution to an endogenous a problem if
your researcher the key is there's no
way around this you have to do an
experiment you can't just do one of
these observational studies you have to
do a natural experiment field experiment
we have different names for this but you
have to do something like an experiment
and the same thing is true when you want
to measure media effects you hate
because of this in dodging a T problem
you have to do an experiment okay so
within the Media Studies field within
communications departments where they do
media effects that it's almost criminal
how bad the the research is I would
estimate something like eighty or ninety
percent maybe a hundred percent of the
professors do not understand this do not
understand what it in dodging a problem
is in my book I decided it was time to
stop being polite and I needed to point
this out and so what I did in my
impoliteness I quote The Simpsons
okay here's what here's here's the quote
it turns out there's an episode where
Homer is driving the halftime float and
he accidentally runs over the leg of the
star kicker Anton would chenko in the
locker room Anton Lenco is talking to
dr. Hibbert and dr. Hibbert says son I'm
afraid that legs hanging by thread with
chinko says chinko must return to game
and dr. Hibbert chuckling says and I'm
afraid your playing days are over but
you can always fall back on your degree
in Reed's chart communications oh dear
Lord Jenko says I know is phony major
look jingo learn nothing
the cries okay at the risk of offending
communication but by the way my wife is
a communications major I think there are
lots and lots of very smart
communications majors but when I use
this I direct it only to that very small
subset that professors and
communications who do Studies on media
effects it's by and large they just do
not get the fact that you need to you
have an in dodging and you need to do an
experiment okay so what I do in my book
I look for the few cases where there is
an experiment so as far as I'm aware
there are only three papers at least
look at the US media that do an
experiment that tried to estimate media
effects through an experiment one of
them the lead author is Alan Gerber I
happen to see him I was visiting Yale
University where I remember where I was
we were having coffee in this bookstore
and he started telling me this
experiment he was going to said we've
got tons of money at Yale so I've got
twenty thousand dollars I can do this
experiment I have behind my research
assistants we've called up people in the
Washington DC suburbs for Northern
Virginia suburbs and we've called them
and before calling them we will flip a
coin and if it's heads we'll say hey
we'll offer you a subscription to The
Washington Times if its tail's it said
we'll offer you a subscription
Washington Post said and we'll pay for
it so you had all this money to do this
so this is a real experiment he has a
control and a treatment group washing
time subscribers Washington Post
subscribers and sure enough he found in
effect the Washington Post subscribers
voted after receiving the subscription
is something like six or eight weeks
something like this there is an election
in the meantime and they called them up
asked all of them who they voted for the
Washington Post subscribers sure enough
voted more democratic than the
Washington Times about 3% more now that
sounds small but in Q&A I can talk about
this actually it was large when you
consider that probably a tiny portion of
their news is actually coming from these
newspapers you know when there's
internet and then Fox television news
and talk radio lots of
so that 3% was actually a pretty high so
when I saw him in this coffee shop I
said you know we talked about the bad
state of media effects field and I said
you know I've been agnostic on this I
think there really are no effects you
know I'm feeling there's none and I said
but you know you know I'm gonna let the
data decide my views and that your study
is going to decide my views so you you
tell me as soon as you get the results I
want to hear you know and that that I'll
change my mind if that and sure enough
he did fine so I'll talk more about
these results in a second okay but the
key is remember you got to do an
experiment so here are some estimates
about the effect of the medium okay once
again here may be the case the point to
get coffee again I'm going to talk about
a definition that's a bit of a
mathematical concept and I'll apologize
if it gets a little boring so I want to
define something that I call the media
lambda in the media lambda it's a number
between 0 and 1 and it says to what
degree can the media influence our views
if it's 0 it means I can at all if it's
1 that means they're all powerful like
the every other effect is nothing every
the media completely determines our view
limit to give away the punchline I find
it about 0.7 I found the media has about
of all the factors that can affect our
views you know our parents our DNA our
old college professors 70% of those
factors are the media I find a very high
number by in fact it says that I may
have gone into the wrong business if I
want to influence young minds they I'm a
professor that what I should have done
has been a journalist okay but if my
media lambda estimate is right then I
that means I went into the wrong
profession okay here's how I define it I
said what it is is for every unit change
in the slant that is the SQ of the media
you look to see how much of voters PQ
moves you know what fraction of that
slant
that fraction is the media lambda so for
instance if you could do an experiment
make the media be ten points more
liberal and then you say how you know
and if the media lambda predicts that
the voters would see if the SQ moves ten
points and the media Atlantis's the the
PQ will move lambda times ten points
okay so if it's point seven it says it
would move seven points to the left
similarly if the media moves twenty
points to the right media lambda with my
estimate says that voter would move 0.7
times twenty or fourteen points to the
right okay so that's what that media
lambda means anyone is the very earth
math you may notice that I have a
linearity assumption involved with that
I won't discuss what that means I'm
happy to in the QA but we could graph it
like that
that also means if you want to measure
the media lambda here's what you do
you have to do an experiment where you
change the slant of the media that a
voter receives and then you observe how
much his political quotient changes you
just divide the second by the first then
that that is your estimate of lambda
okay and that's what I do
in my book by the way for that LA Times
example if you remember the numbers I
said I said I think it was about fifty
was the change in the PQ about forty was
a change and they asked you that would
give you an estimate of 1.25 as this
media lambda there's theoretical reasons
to say that really that that number
can't be but has to be between zero and
one it can't be greater than one so that
one point two five has got to be wrong
and we talked about the endogenous
it to appear bigger than it really is
and that that seems to be what happened
okay but here's what I do so I take
those three papers to do an experiment
and I say let's look at the data let's
use what they find the change in the
slant look at the change in the
political quotient let's get an estimate
of the lambda the three different papers
give a different number it turns out
they're kind of all
over the place in fact that paper by
Alan Gerber and his colleagues at Yale
gets a point nine five is it's super
high and it has a huge standard of error
on it it turns out that you can't reject
media lambda0 you nor can you reject a
media lambda1 the margin of error is
greater than one the reason is because
they only had something like 800 nothing
is 1,200 they had something like 1200
subjects in their sample they should
have had something like 120,000 to get
tight balance on this now remember
they're paying for a newspaper
subscription for every one of those
subjects so I fault them for not having
a hundred twenty thousand that you know
that was something like $20.00 a
subscription so you can do the math that
would have been a very very expensive
study so to get a tight bound it's going
to be very very hard okay one other
example I think I want to get to the
question and answer but I have a good
example of a friend of mine as a
politician just became a congressman
when he was a state senator he was
facing this vote on the death penalty
even though he's conservative zecha
moderate on the death penalty he that he
was a state senator in Maryland the
state Senate was about thinking about
having moratorium on the death penalty
for two years he couldn't decide how he
was gonna vote and so I knew him I knew
his brother really well and God is here
I said hey why don't you do something
you know there's this problem we don't
know what the deterrent effects are on
the death penalty so you know what we
need is an experiment maybe you could
you could allow it to happen so why
don't you put an amendment to this bill
and make the death penalty have a
moratorium every other month in Maryland
or in every other County you pick
randomly and he listened to me and said
you know I I think you have a good idea
I understand the dodging a problems and
if I did that I just I just think my
constituents would laugh at me and yeah
I guess so so you can see why it's very
very hard in social science ever
together in a true experiment and so you
know my fault those other three papers
for not having tight bounds on their
estimates I fault other social
scientists for not doing more
experiments
you know maybe in there and our defense
you know it's very hard to do
experiments and social science and
there's no surprise we don't have that
many ok so here's what I conclude I take
those three estimates from those three
papers you know I say let's just take
the average of them and I get 0.7 okay
so once again that means about 70% if
you take all the factors that influence
our views
this says that 70% of the weight goes on
the media there's only the other there's
only 30% left for all the other other
factors so I think this is a
surprisingly high estimate of the
effects of the media okay
the final part let me get the punchline
how would America think and vote if the
media weren't biased and here's the
thought experiment I do so recall the
the old graph where I found the media is
about at a 58 the slant the average
voter is about a 54 in this thought
experiment said let's make the media
report like the average voter would want
the media to okay now I think to do this
I think it's probably twenty two hundred
thousand journalists in America I'm not
sure what the number is but you'd have
to do something like clone cheryl
atkinson something like twenty to forty
thousand times make all those clones get
jobs in the media okay it's imagine that
world where all of a sudden they they
you do all those clones of shrill
atkinson there's all these new reporters
and all of a sudden that changes the
slant from fifty eight to fifty okay if
that really happened i think what would
happen what would happen is the other
journalists would rightly say well if we
do that we're gonna cause voters to be
cut to move right if there's so many new
cheryl atkinson xin them in the newsroom
the voter is not going to stay at fifty
point four but that voters going to move
right okay and in fact my results give a
precise prediction of that it's as the
voter if we move the
slant eight points to the right we're
gonna move the PQ of the average voter
0.7 times those eight points that's
about five point five so we would if we
did that experiment we would move the
average voter to forty four point seven
and those journalists would be right
yeah the voter actually moved to the
right and that voter now thinks it's at
forty four point seven doesn't think
we're centrist anymore that voter thinks
centrist is forty four now so if you
keep doing this experiment it's
something like Zeno's paradox but you
keep repeating this and you look for a
stable point a point where the media has
finally caught up to where the voters
views are it's a math problem but you
could you can estimate where would it be
and the answer is about thirty one point
five okay in my book I explained I made
some assumptions to try to err against
my own conclusion so I think the true
number would probably be a little bit
smaller than thirty one point five maybe
twenty five to thirty somewhere in there
okay so you may wonder what is twenty
five to thirty mean using I can estimate
the PQ of different states different
counties I find that's about Texas okay
Texas has average voter as a peak of
about twenty seven another example would
be something like West Virginia or
Kentucky so that is my final the put to
conclusions is that the the the the the
main two takeaway points I think from
this talk it's one the media according
my results cording these experiments
really does have an effect it really
can't affect how we think and vote the
other is that according to my results if
it weren't for the bias America would
think and vote uh prompts me like Texas
rather than the way it currently does so
I will in there and take some questions
thank you
we have the microphones coming please
raise your hand and stand when you ask
the question and we have quite a bit of
time for questions so please ask our
learner professor here all the questions
we also encourage student questions and
if you read the syllabus the few of you
who did you could get extra credit for
accessing good questions so thank you
very much I wanted to ask in all of your
calculations and so forth
is there any do you factor in the fact
that with a lot of newspapers let's say
the Boston Globe for instance that their
circulation is plummeting or the New
York Times circulation is plummeting the
the network alphabet soup of news
outlets are some of the more left-wing
cable outlets they don't you know if for
CNN if it wasn't shown in hospitals or
the airports no one would watch it you
know is it you know I know what you're
saying is the influence but there's
fewer people watching and consuming it
from those particular outlets is that
factored in at all or is that is that
something to consider
excellent point let me just say the the
short answer is no that I it's a static
analysis and in my defense it takes
about a month or some like three weeks
actually get all the data for every one
of those news outlets and this took me
something like eight years to write this
book and so I did those 20 news outlets
and some people say well I didn't do
this one that's oh gosh that would take
so long so I picked a particular point
of time it was kind of the early 2000s
so that's when all of these results hold
for so of course since that time though
he's at the time Fox News had about the
same viewership as like CNN you know it
was during the late 90s
much less and it's a paestum sometime in
the early 2000s and now it's something
like two and a half I think times the
viewership of CNN so that would have
changed things now
I didn't look at MSNBC but if you
remember an MSNBC during the early 2000
was was actually kind of moderate it did
not have the Keith Olbermann so in some
ways my estimates of the media slant
would move more conservative because
more people are watching Fox but the
other hand MSNBC didn't at least the
left-wing version didn't exist so I'm
not sure I can speculate you know on
what it would be but but I think that's
a good point yeah definitely you see the
the numbers at the definitely net
network news it used to be they would
get some like 15 million or more viewers
now it's down to something like 7
million a night so that's plummeting so
uh I think it would be pretty similar
but but I I don't know hi there thanks a
lot for your talk um I just wanted to
ask what would you say if there was an
objection to calculating all liberal
conservative differences of opinion
along one axis as opposed I guess just
what would the margin of error be for
simplifying a number of different fields
to one graph you know excellent point
yeah I won't go back to the slide but if
you remember the slide although I get
that a lot at George Mason I'm one of
the few people who calls himself a
conservative lots of libertarians are at
George Mason they they tell me that look
you've collapsed everything to one
left/right dimension we're really you
know we need two or more to describe and
for instance Ron Paul on this is peak
hue is about a 30 on this which put some
kind of a right-leaning moderate okay
now Ron Paul is really not a moderate on
anything
extreme right on economics extreme left
on foreign policy but he averages out
and gets you know about a 30 he's about
the same scores Rick Lazio if you may
remember him he was the guy who ran
against Hillary Clinton the first time
she ran for Senate I think he really is
a true moderate he's kind of moderate on
every issue and so but in no way would
you say Rick Lazio's views are like Ron
Paul's you know they just kind of
averaged out in my artificial way the
way to account for that is just use two
dimensions now I used for my PQ scores I
looked at an interest group called the
Americans for democratic action they are
liberal interest group that that they
picked 10 or 20 votes every year in
Congress and I used those votes I could
have used to I could have picked
something like a National Taxpayers
Union for economic scores Family
Research Council for Social Policy and
I'm sure there's some other for foreign
policy the the problem is just be more
work but I hope I've been hoping to get
a grad student to do this it wouldn't be
that much work so you could give a
two-dimensional PQ your PQ on economic
is your three-dimensional and then it
really wouldn't take that much work you
just take the the statistical programs
we wrote that Milo and I wrote you just
make some minor adjustments put in these
three dimensions and you could estimate
everything on these three dimensions so
the short answer is good point that the
three to your question the C I can
speculate on what would happen there's a
lot of people who say a lot of media
scholars who say yeah maybe the the
media really is biased to the left on
social policy they say I don't think it
is on economic policy so they're all
free traders all the and that may be but
I do another chapter where I use a
different method to as
made the media bias I look at the facts
the media reported about the Bush tax
cuts and I won't go to the details but I
found that they were actually even more
to the left on this so that was a pure
economic issue and I found that they
were actually moved to the left now you
could say all that was not a good way to
study it maybe so but my hunch is that
that would not be true that the media
would be if you do the study right like
I suggest for those three dimensions
you'd find the media really is to the
left on economic issues to dr.
Groseclose thank you for your thank you
for your talk and two questions one I
was wondering what you think the factors
for West Virginia Kentucky in Texas to
have that number of 30 or whatever it is
you know why do they have that in other
states like Minnesota where I'm from I
don't know what Minnesota would be but
you know why what's the difference and
then secondly I know this doesn't have
anything to do with your talk right now
but your book about the about UCLA and
the and the the findings that you did
and and the fact that you were on the
staff there and faculty there and how
did that all come about and maybe speak
about that a little bit about that book
or or how well the reaction just you're
writing that book in your findings and
how that all came out and how you were
received after that yeah yeah first you
know I don't know about you know why
these states change the way they do in
fact I've looked at it before and it's
consistent with the random walk I won't
go through the math of what that means
but it's like there really it's hard to
predict you know at the end so I really
don't know so there's something I I
think it's worth the entry it didn't
used to be that cities were all so
liberal the big cities are all very
liberal didn't used to be that way you
know not the same degree and I think
that is an interesting
question that I as far as no one's
addressed it and I think that's part of
the reason why these states have changed
so the answer is I don't know to that
how did people react at UCLA let's see
so man I could I could talk hours on
this let's see what although first when
the article came out so I did that with
my low you know that was fine
you know I was a little worried and I
kind of waited to get tenure before I
did that
oh you're brave no no I'm not no I
waited until I got tenure and actually I
got a promotion after that now it was
published in one of the prestigious
economics journals and so you know that
was one like that
the book had a different effect I think
the title I you know I wanted a title
that would catch people's attention you
know I thought about calling it
distortion but I know no in fact I told
mine I had a literary agent and I told
her I said you know look whatever it
when you're going to publishers is
telling I'm not David Brooks I don't a
lot of them wanted a David Brooks you
know a conservatives that liberals could
like no that's not me that's not me so I
wrote the book and let's see in the
meantime I'd resign from the admissions
committee and protest when I saw the
cheater using race and emissions and it
went to the press I was a whistleblower
on and that wasn't popular on that but
you know what though but privately there
are a lot of professor would say yeah
we're going way too far on that then we
are breaking lon
I'm very queasy I'm glad you know you
did what you did no one no one would say
that publicly or almost no one but lots
would say that privately there was a for
a lot of reason that you know I still
have friends there but you know the time
you know when you live in LA you meet
all kinds of people in Hollywood and I
had a friend that worked at Showtime he
thought you might remember this show I
think it's so long called we
it's about the single mom that makes
money selling marijuana the sky's a
conservative devout Christian he just
hated working at Showtime he says it
goes against all my values and he
retired as soon as he could and I kind
of felt that way about UCLA after a
while I said this goes against all my
values and when you're trying to do
things like make your institution better
that's somewhat you just don't feel
right about doing it and so I was ready
to leave my wife was not all right kids
were not but then at one point it's like
this automatic promotion and it was
probably based on the research I did for
this book and I got this review that
really made me angry that I got denied
this promotion but the the committee
evaluating me I'm sure didn't read the
book and so anyway I came home and told
my wife did get the promotion it didn't
really matter the title but these
automatic promotions that it came with a
four to eight percent pay raise okay
and so as you know academia we have
tenure which means that you get some
Deadwood professors and I would estimate
they UCLA
something five to twenty percent not but
there's some Deadwood professors but
ever I came home I told my wife I'm not
getting the promotion she was furious
she said well you should become Deadwood
and said if they're not going to give
you so that did it and I think you know
I want to say this I don't think there
was anyone in the upper administration I
don't think they were going to dare
retaliate against me their whistleblower
protection laws in California I don't
think the Chancellor Dean's any of them
what would happen was when it was this
anonymous committee evaluating me where
they could kind of stab me in the back
without anyone knowing it that's when I
got that unfavorable promotion which
ticked off my wife which eventually led
and at the same time right almost a few
weeks after that I got a call from
George Mason I have lots of friends
there and in a friend Alec Stavrou I
called me I said you called exactly the
right time and so and I'm pretty soon
moved there
since Edith Ephron wrote a book back in
1968 after this the Humphrey Nixon
election conservatives have been quite
concerned about media bias but year
after year it seems to make very little
difference as far as the behavior of the
media is concerned in fact speaking of
David Brock I read his book on the
right-wing propaganda machine or what
have you called that and he said that
that the liberal journalists aren't
really liberal they're just being
journalists and the problem with
conservatives is they have a political
bias so for us this is useful
information that confirms our opinion of
the media but as a practical matter what
can it do to actually affect any change
in the media yeah I think you're right
there
they ain't changing that I mean you know
fact I here's the problem no one's
written about this that supposedly did
try to change that you know suppose all
of a sudden CBS News said you know
cheryl atkinson is right you know
there's by the way let's say let me go
back I said what David Brock's and we
just report the news one of the key
points my book is to talk about what I
call a distortion theory of bias I say
they're not telling lies that you know
maybe there's a few false statements but
the key part of the bias is what they're
not reporting and ensure lacan something
is last night enough she mentioned in
her book about some of the mainstream
journalists they've started saying using
this term oh that's a fox story okay
we're not going to report that that's
and I think a lot of her stories that
were saying our fox story well that's
interesting they've finally admitted
that it's not just a matter of telling
the truth or not right it's it's what
you don't report true stories that you
don't report and I would like to tell
them but like yeah you have your stories
that you think are very important you on
the left
we on the right think we have stories
that are very important that should be
reported we it's a subjective judgement
which should be reported but we differ
on that but what I trend it in my book
is say what would Maude
Ritz want you know what were these 50
people with 50 peak hues in Congress
what would they say and they say yeah
the media should be reporting some of
these Fox stories so what can be done
about it so I never written about this
but I want to soon and I think here's if
you imagine like a CBS News and and
suppose the owner or manager CEO or if
says we have to hire more sure licenses
you know we are we do have a bias and
we've got to change well the problem is
if you started hiring more surely
atkinson's and started reporting news
like she's reporting like Benghazi what
happens is people like us we
conservatives say look this is a major
story even CBS News is reporting it the
the left-wing CBS News and the
journalists at CBS News say well wait
wait wait what we're new were the new
CBS News no no that were the moderate
CBS News it it would take over there
would be a lag and people getting that
perception and the people that the
reporters at CBS News would hate that
that all of a sudden not only with those
stories move people to the right it
would I can I have double the effect so
it's kind of like a Nixon going to China
it's like not only here's this
conservative news story but it's coming
from this left-wing source and and we
the moderates would say oh this must
mean it's really bad and so in that
transition period they would absolutely
hate it and I think that's part of the
reason why they can't move left though
isn't why they can't move to the center
and my feeling is if that happened if
they tried something like that the
reporters who tried it would be
miserable they'd be like me at UCLA like
cheryl atkinson at CBS news and it it
just wouldn't happen so i think that i'm
beginning to think the only way to
change the media bias is for the
mainstream outlets just to die off that
that's the only way they're not going to
change their spots i think but and i
think i think slowly that that might
happen although let me also say one
thing i've noticed
if I can this is another topic but one
reason there's a bias I think is because
there's not enough conservative kids
going in journalism that I've talked I
give talks at the national journalism
Center it's a it's a group that actually
tries to get conservative kids to go
into journalism and even those kids who
are there so yeah I'm not sure I'm not
sure if I saw John Miller's program if
we could double it that that would be
one way to help do this we need more
conservative kids going into journalism
and I think that would that would do
wonders we need to do that I have one
for you right here yeah last night when
Cheryl said that about half of her
emails came from people who felt the
Democrats were on target and the other
half went came from Republicans who felt
like Obama was way off target you know I
wondered how can this be but your talk
today has shown me what's wrong she's
got of PQ of 50 and a liberal bias of 75
probably so or a media bias so most of
the people who send her emails or many
are her fans and they tend to cluster
together it seems to me you know I would
defend her though you know I think I
don't know she has a PQ of 50 I hope she
will report it to me that's just my
speculation and I and I haven't done a
careful study of hers but but I actually
think that during the Obama Obama
administration her s Q where she's been
reports she's been reporting the
Benghazi inand fast and furious I mean I
would put her s q a little bit
right-of-center although I think that
when Bush was president she hadn't asked
you left-of-centre I think she has been
just kind of critical of whoever's in
office but I guess I have to plead
guilty I didn't
maybe I wasn't paying attention when she
talked about her emails but she thought
she got a balance
of emails well yeah you have to remember
though that you know how many
conservatives are watching CBS news
right this uh there is probably a you
know by a sample of where those emails
would come from this might piggyback on
that last point I was wondering to your
knowledge have you been any of these
studies on social media sites such as
Twitter or Facebook or even like the
larger entertainment industry you know
in a whole and their effect on the
younger generations you know yeah good
point I don't know yeah when I when I
wrote my book barely heard of Twitter I
love it now but so I I'm not sure in the
the the media I mean the excuse me the
the entertainment yeah I think that that
is a big source quick story I was
watching with my TV with my daughter 13
years old and and she is forced to watch
the news c-span even sometimes because I
have the promote and one time when
instead we're watching Entertainment
Tonight and she said wow this news is
interesting missus and so people like my
specially younger kids and I've been mid
even when I was in college I don't think
I watch the news I was not that news
junky I am today
so and I have a feeling like this just
casual casual observation but the the
entertainment news is probably gonna be
more left than then even like CBS and
NBC and ABC so but it would be worthy to
do a study that um I was just wondering
your Landa when you found that you just
used three experiments so I was
wondering how much trust you have in
that land of value and also um I'm an
econ major here and in our smart classes
we read a couple pieces by Paul Krugman
and in those pieces Paul Krugman just
attacks the media which is how little
just general
education they have and how very little
they understand about it yes I was
wondering how much do you think if the
media had some more basic knowledge of
economics how much it would that affect
the bias in the media that's a point by
the way I think one of the most
important top 100 pieces ever written on
economics is a piece by Krugman he has a
piece if you google Krugman comparative
advantage maybe what you read he talks
about the lack of economic he kind of
agrees with Jonathan Gruber but you
talked about how few people understand
the law of comparative advantage by the
way I think to have an excellent
undergrad education you learn in dodging
80 problems you might learn a symbolic
logic class the number thing who
Whittaker Chambers is but another one
would be what is the law of comparative
advantage it's a tricky concept and it's
a very important one that's you know
exists since David Ricardo but Krugman
writes about this and Krugman actually
sounds like a conservative in this piece
he's talking about how few people
understand it and he says especially
journalists in it and he comes to the
collusion he's I think some people just
don't have the mental firepower ever to
get this and he kind of says something
like especially journalists he's very
critical of them and so yeah I think
that if we could just have some more
economics education especially wouldn't
in dodging a ax T problem is I think it
would by the way there's a whole sub
industry of these little studies saying
how Fox News is fooling voters there to
say how Fox News's are the viewers are
stupider than the average all of those
studies have an endogenous a problem the
other things they rigged the questions
that's one problem but another no one
talks about it's just that there's an
Adagio a problem if the but in most of
those studies here's another secret
there's something like four or five out
there that peer-reviewed studies that
could somehow can conclude that Fox News
viewers are less informed than all the
others a well-kept secret is almost
office all the studies are not pop
in the top peer-reviewed journals there
in like the third or fourth tier all of
those and I think because the the really
good social scientists understanding
dodging 80 problem they don't accept
them at the at the top tiers but
meanwhile they're published in these
not-so-good journals but the the the
journalists picked these up they you'll
love to talk about how Fox News viewers
are not as informed as the rest if those
journalists could just learn what an
endogenous when it would a law of
comparative advantages I think that
would be very very very helpful let's
see the other question you asked about
my confidence in the media lambda let me
say I don't have that much ice I say 0.7
I don't even report a confidence
interval I think it would be HUGE if I
could I'm not exactly sure how to do the
math to estimate a confidence interval
because given that it comes from three
different studies I'm pretty confident
that the 0.9 is probably too high but
I'm also confident that that it's at
least point three it's you know that's a
big range but but I think it's it's
definitely positive the other thing
there are some other studies there's a
recent one that came memories from but
he looked at and this incredible so
remember how hard it is to do an
experiment in social science what this
guy did looked at Russian media and it
looked to see how vote the extent of
which voters were Pro Putin or anti
Putin and so what he had is he had this
radio station that happened to be anti
Putin and then he looked at weather
patterns and it turns out there were
some days where you couldn't get this
radio station on other days where he and
he looked at the number of days a
different region could get this station
and so it was the weather determining
what was the control group in the
treatment group so it was almost like a
laboratory experiment and he found huge
effects that this that seemed that that
weather you know causing the radio
station to be available or not that
caused a huge effect on whether your
pro-putin or anti-putin so I think
there's some more confirmation from you
know other experiments that's saying
that yeah it looks like this media
lambda is pretty high so you know I
think it's making me think that yeah
maybe it is even you know I'm more
confident that it's greater than 0.5
which means that you know again that the
views we see are artificial that really
if the voters wouldn't have to face this
media bias that everyone would be a
little bit more conservative we actually
have time for one more question so we'll
take it right over here and then he'll
be available for questions down here and
also be signing his his new book new
book left turn over here
after the speech so one more question
and then we'll break as a wall as a Wall
Street Journal reader I'd like to ask
you for some follow up on your wall
street journal comments earlier in your
talk and also ask you if the report that
one on newspaper circulation from a year
or two ago which showed that the wall
street journal was the only major print
publication with increasing readership
is still the case let's see ya don't one
I don't let's see - yeah I'm not as
familiar with the readership I did try
to keep track of every time you see a
report it's it's because they're there
their numbers are falling it's almost
every time and what I always try to
calculate what would be the half life
whatever and it's I think it's something
like 15 years according to my
calculations that the the revenue to any
given newspaper and I think it's also
true for TV about every 15 years it's
going to have I think that's going to
happen so in 45 years for now it'll be
like eight one eighth of what it is in
miss MSNBC is even more my calculations
something like 20 I can't remember what
oh I think it's like 15 years I'm like
that
MSNBC's your
if it's going to be 1/32 what it
currently is that they've got to be
worried and in as MSME see it is
interesting the Wall Street Journal that
in addition if you read Sheryl
atkinson's book you know she talks about
all these these are interesting stories
these are scoops she has and and yet her
bosses are squelching these stories and
you can kind of see I think that you
know I think part of it is these
technological factors the the internet
but part of it is just there's these
great stories out there that the
mainstream media is failing to report
Fox News also is staying about even
maybe even slightly increasing meanwhile
at CNN nemecio meteors are falling it
wasn't a where Wall Street Journal is is
keeping the same number what's
interesting is you have to pay to get
the Wall Street Journal's are actually
getting money now why did I find the
estimate I found so one I found the Wall
Street Journal is actually slightly more
liberal than the New York Times okay now
that was a controversial finding curious
I thought something may been wrong with
my method when I found it even okay but
one remember that it turns out III
didn't discuss I have three different
sources of data the three different
methods I focused on the think-tank
method that was the one with the
original peer-reviewed article it turns
out that think-tank method just didn't
do a good job at estimating opinion
pieces it seems like what would happen
is the opinion writer would often say
I'm a conservative opinion writer I
might quote a left wing think-tank
almost as a straw man and then to
explain why it's wrong so I'm giving
like you know short shrift to this
think-tank quote and then lots of lots
of space to the other side meanwhile I'm
not siding a think-tank for the other
side so my method would only record the
think-tank citation of the left-wing
thing
even though the article mainly focused
on right-wing points I think that's why
my method just didn't work that well
with Abed's so I we just my co-author
and I we just took out all the op eds we
focused only on the news so so with that
result says that the news pages of the
Wall Street Journal are actually to the
left of most of the other mainstream
news outlets now even that was a
surprise now I should mention that the
data came from early 2000s I think it
was 2002 and 2003 when that happened
there may have been something special
about that for some reason that the Wall
Street Journal was not citing
conservative think-tanks or something
instead they were citing conservatives
elsewhere that that could have been the
problem with that the other thing
remember now it's owned by Rupert
Murdoch when I did my study it was not
it was owned by the Dow Jones
Corporation I think it was mainly I
think the owners probably leaned left
even well but I have some anecdotes even
of that say why maybe the news pages are
slightly slow probably not now it's
probably shifted a little bit if I redid
the study now now that Rupert Murdoch as
is now the owner or or I think what is
it the News Corporation is now the owner
of Wall Street Journal but still there
there's some reason so you know I'm even
on a little bit skeptical I think that
it's probably about like New York Times
but and there may be some anomalous
reasons why I found that it was slightly
to the left of New York Times
okay please join me in thanking thanking
dr. gross close